हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखे हिंदी में
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाले हैं पर्सनल प्रोनोस के
नॉमिनेटिव पूजा के मोड सेटिंग शुरू
यह तो यह तो क्लियर है कि इससे पहले आपको
आपको नॉमिनेटिव पॉजिटिव केसेस क्या है यह
पता होनी चाहिए तो मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि अगर आपके अभी तक केस क्लियर
नहीं है तो वह वीडियोस देख लीजिए क्योंकि
अगर वह वीडियोस आपने देखिए तो आज का जो
कंसेप्ट है वह बहुत क्लियर है तो आप
बोलोगे कि पर्सनल प्रॉब्लम तो हमने पहले
एपिसोड में देखें इस ड्रेस तो आज हम क्या
देखने वाले हैं तो आज हम उनके आपको ट्यूम
रखेंगे मतलब क्या अभी हिंदी में देखो मैं
किरदार हूं पर अगर वो भी मुझे चाय देती है
तो वी मैं चाय नहीं देती थी वह मुझे चाय
देती है यह मैं का मुझे क्यों व क्योंकि
मैं इसमें इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट था
सिमिलरली इंग्लिश में आए हम केदार आई एम
इधर प्रजा मेरी बेटी होगी उससे प्यार करती
है तो विल लव से आए नहीं वह भी लव मी अब
यह आएगा me kyu Waqt कि इस सेंटेंस में
मैं ऑब्जेक्ट था
ए सिमिलर केसेस जर्मन में भी होती है और
जब आप नॉमिनेटिव आपको छोटी हो या डाइटरी
वह उसके हिसाब से आप इस अगर मराठी है तो
कि आपको ट्यूब है तो मैं ऐड किया है तो
मेयर यूज करूंगी कैसे हम थोड़े एग्जांपल्स
देखते हैं सबसे पहले जो में सबसे पहले
देखा है आई एम किरदार स्पिन केंद्र प्लेयर
हाईट अभी तो व्हीलर ज़मीन भी लव मी
सब्जेक्ट कौन है वहीं मैं क्या हूं मैं
जुट हूं तो इसीलिए अक्षर के है तो क्या हो
गया हमने देखा है मिस ओवी लिमिट मिस
कल क्रिकेट
ए मूवी प्लेस विथ मी आपको मिर्च मतलब क्या
याद है डोंट यू विद है तो मेड स्टीव है तो
टाइपिंग क्या है इसका नियर इसलिए ओवीस
प्रिंट मिनट नियर सिंपल रेगुलर तीन
सेंटेंस याद रखो आपको कंसेप्ट गई इस विद
केदार क्योंकि मैं नॉमिनेटिव विल लिफ्ट
मिर्च क्योंकि मैं आपको बताती हूं वो भी
स्पीडोमीटर क्योंकि मैं डालती हूं यह
क्लियर है तो वैसे ही दूरदृष्टि अ यू आर
के अंदर 2 मिनट के दार मूवी लव यू विल
लिफ्ट दी होगी प्लेस मृत्यु मूवी स्पीड यह
ए सिंपल है बट अगर यह क्लियर है तो आपको
स्क्रीन पर एक टेबल दिख रहा होगा अब
एक्चुअली फ्रेंकली स्पीकिंग यह वन के लिए
इस बीच में है दूरदृष्टि अरे इनफ है पर
योनी में हमको FD को जाना ही है और अंडर
थम ओं स्ट्रिंग यू विल गेट इस मिश्रण भर
दीजिए अब बाकि कि आपको बहुत कम लगेंगे पर
हम आज सीख लेते हैं वह तो जैसे मैं का
मुझे होता है तो वह का उससे भी होता है
राइट तो वह भी आज हम सारा सीरियल हैं तो
अगर आप देखोगे ही मतलब हेयर उसका पूरा टीम
एक इन थे डायरेक्टिव है ईमेल
कि यह थिंग यह सब्जेक्ट होगा तो होगा और
ऑब्जेक्ट तो यह डाट यह बहुत ही इजी है जी
का पूजा ठीक है डाट यह सिर्फ शेयर होता है
इसका जिससे इसका पॉजिटिव ऐड कि सिर्फ
मीडियम होता है फिर देर के लिए इजी है बैक
का पोर्शन स्टार्टिंग दोनों कौन है यह
काफी एक्टिव पार्ट इन दोनों वायर्स है और
फिर दोनों बड़े और छोटे जी को अकोर्डिंग
जी रहे घर और डाट यह बन जाएगा वैसे ज्यादा
नहीं आर्ट सदस्य वर्ड्स सीख रहे हो तपन
ट्रिक थे तब हर रोज सिर्फ एक ही रोशनी और
उसके तीन सेंटेंस करके देखो आपको क्लियर
हो जाएगा
कि हम थोड़े सेंटेंस बनाते हैं तो और
थोड़ा कॉन्फिडेंस आएगा इश्क और दूं कि
हमने 3 सेंटेंस बनाए थे बाकी के भी
सेंटर्स हम बनाकर देखते हैं अब यह टेबल
देखते ही रहो आई प्ले विद हिम विद मतलब
क्या डांटते हुए ही का गठन किया है तेल
में को भी टीम स्पीड लिमिट इन ही सिंपल है
और मिसरी वेजिटेबल्स ज्यादा देवदास में
यात्री भवन है इजी है राइट अभी आई खूब फॉर
हर इक फॉर हर क्या होगा और इस सर्कुलर कि
अगर आपको याद हो तो तो ठीक उलट इन जी इसको
ख्यूरा सीईए
मैं अभी आपको याद होगा आई एम लविंग मिर्च
हमने देखा था मैडम नमस्कार तो वह क्या
होता है 30 दिव्य इसलिए वह सभी टैब्स
क्यों हुआ तो अगर आप इसमें देखोगे तो एप्स
ऑब्जेक्ट है तो आप उसे क्योंकि इसका ऐसी
होता है तो इसीलिए फिर से होगा इसलिए डैडी
क्लियर है
है कि लफ्ज़ ही लव्स ऊ अगेन हम क्या है सब
लोग कुलसचिव अब जेट तो क्या होगा ए ग्लू
कुनै न कुनै होगा और आई प्ले विद हिम मैं
उनके साथ खेलता हूं तो विद क्या है ट्यून
और देश का डाट यह देखो कि नंदिश स्पीड
लिमिट इन थे अज्ञेय 5 सेंटेंसेस
हैं तो इस सिंपल हमने पहले भी तीन-तीन
विकेट देखिए और यह पांच आपको क्या करना है
सिर्फ यह समझ लो और पिंग आपको और एक
प्रशिक्षु सेंटेंस करता हूं आई लव यू जो
होता है आई लव यू जर्मन में कैसे होगा
देखो मेट्रो सब्जेक्ट हूं इसलिए मैं तो इस
चूर्ण का यहां पर आप यूज तुम हो क्या
पॉकेट हो और ऑब्जेक्ट दूंगा क्या होता है
डिश इसलिए आई लव यू जर्मन में बनता है इस
लिंबोदी इसलिए अवधि अगर यह याद रखोगे
बूटेबल अगर आपने किया है अगर आप आठ-दस दिन
करोगे तो आप यह कंसेप्ट क्लियर हो जाएगी
बहुत सिंपल है डिश लीटर दूध ईयर इत्सेल्फ
नॉट अट ऑल लोग उसको कंसेप्चुअल नहीं समझते
इसीलिए लोगों को वह ज्यादा में इसका यूज
करूं इसका यूज करूं यार का यूज कर होता है
कल सिर्फ चोली समझ लो नॉमिनेटिव तो यह
आपको एक्टिवेट हो मिस्टर में कमी अ अ
है आई होप आप सबको एक कंसेप्ट समझ में आई
होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद है